so there's a lot of misinformation about
what's working on YouTube right now so
in this video I'm going to be breaking
down a secret that I found on YouTube
that ultimately helped me get not just
only a gold play button uh but three
silver play buttons and you can apply
this in 2024 I want to wish you a happy
New Year and what's cool about this
strategy is that you don't need a better
camera you don't need any significant
levels of talent you don't really need
to improve your video skills and you
actually don't even need be very
consistent with this strategy I actually
found a cool way to ethically hack into
people's brains the power of using the
YouTube search bar which is free to come
up with video ideas that people uh
ultimately want to watch and to come up
with Evergreen video ideas why is this
such a secret well the problem that 99%
of creators struggle with is they're
making videos that nobody wants to watch
or they're looking for video ideas and
they're looking in all the wrong places
like some people are also looking for
love in all the wrong places um but
ultimately we're going to use these
three title uh um formulas and the first
one number one is how to number one is
how to so for DIY in woodworking is our
first Niche from the dad cave and I'll
switch up the niche on each formula um
we're going to go to the YouTube search
bar and we're going to type in how
to build a
table okay so ultimately what we're
tapping into in this this powerful
secret maybe you've heard of this before
but most people don't understand even
how to use this tool or or ways to use
it so I promise you you're going to get
a couple insites they're going to help
you get more views in 2024 so what we're
using is when we tap into the YouTube
search bar it's doing a couple things
for us number one it's revealing what
people are actually searching so if you
type in howto it's the predictions this
autocomplete is letting us know what
people are actually searching so if you
have a
woodworking channel so you could type in
Woodworking and immediately you start
getting all kinds of vide topic ideas
woodworking projects that sell wood
working project ideas woodworking tools
great so you can take your topic your
Niche and you can start
brainstorming different video ideas now
this is better than AI this is better
than other tools those tools are fine
too but the reason this is powerful is
because it's actually Based on data of
what people are actually searching on
YouTube so it's verified that people are
interested in these topics it's not just
like hey chat GPT like what are 30 video
ideas like okay great but those are just
video ideas what if we could actually
verify what people are interested in and
so if we take in something like
woodworking uh you can take your topic
and you could say how
to and even though how to woodworking is
kind of a bad sentence um immediately I
start getting this
rich list ordered by most search to Le
searched so how to do woodworking
projects how to woodwork video how to
start woodworking as a hobby how to
start a woodworking business and then
this is where things like human
psychology come in in such an important
way for example human psychology
understanding of who are you trying to
reach on YouTube understanding of what's
the type of person you're talking to and
what I mean by that is you know if if
you're trying to do YouTube work uh
woodworking as a hobby versus as a
business that's like too entirely
different mindsets so it'll help us kind
of drill down and what we can do is you
don't just like take it at face value if
it's how to start woodworking as a a
hobby or how to set up a woodworking
shop this is why the first Formula of
how to is is what you want to start
playing with like how to build a
DIY could be the next thing you think
about because uh the co the uh Community
member that shared this Niche shared DIY
in woodworking so how to build a DIY
chair and then DIY how to build a
folding campfire chair maybe irrelevant
because you're not going to do folding
stuff but maybe you are so you start you
start going down this robbit hole how to
build a do-it-yourself
table would and and then a couple things
that we begin to learn one if if you hit
a dead end and nothing is predicted it
should cause you to pause two if you hit
a dead end it's okay to go back and then
start reworking it because if you go
well Sean it doesn't work for me nothing
is predicted that should cause you pause
because that would indicate that no one
is looking for those videos now you
doesn't mean you can't make that video
there's a whole other approach to
YouTube by having a lot of curios even
the title of this video is I found a
YouTube secret that's not actually a
search it's not a howto term it's even a
different approach in the way I packaged
this but don't get it twisted one of the
best ways to start is to start with the
search based revealed by YouTube
insights that YouTube gives you in fact
I'll give you three reasons why this is
so powerful and we'll go into these
other formulas as well but the reason
this is so powerful is because again
hereo think media our commitment to you
this years to help you win on YouTube
help you get into the top 2% of YouTube
creators which means get over 10,000
subscribers help you do this
full-time and also we've we deeply study
not just sort of like the what to do
because everybody knows what to do like
everybody knows that it's New Year's and
like you should eat better and like work
out and like cut out toxic friends but
the what to do actually isn't the hard
part it's more like the psychology the
moment how do I get myself motivated how
do I get out of a rut so the three
reasons why this is powerful is because
you start with easy videos like when you
reveal when we some of the formulas that
we're going to use and what it's going
to reveal for us are going to give us
what we're looking for is like oh
that'll be an easy video some people
over complicate YouTube there are videos
you could make in 2024 sh shot just on
your smartphone you don't need a fancy
camera with very basic beginner
information but the reason why you'll
succeed is because you identified a
particular
topic it wasn't because of a fancy title
or thumbnail let's improve those as well
because you did better research using
the tools that YouTube gives you and in
doing so when you identify a particular
video it doesn't mean that it has to be
hard to be successful so you start with
easy videos number two you start with
videos people want to watch we know that
for sure because if you follow the
process I'm going to be breaking down
here we have verified that people want
to watch them and number three check
this
out you'll get guaranteed views I can't
guarantee you'll go viral you probably
won't but I can guarantee you'll get
views because if you do this right it
will lead to views because instead of
just making random videos that no one's
actually looking for you're creating
strategic videos that people want to see
so title formula number one is how to
let's go to number two which is versus
one of my favorite kind of videos versus
all right so the next topic I'm just
clicking these randomly in streamyard
mra's got a channel on passive income
and Financial Freedom okay so I'm going
to assume
it's maybe personal finance of some kind
or passive income okay so let's talk
versus so let's go back to how to so how
to make passive
income great uh this was number one
formulas how to and then fill in the
blank how to make passive
income um with chat GPT all I'm going to
what I'm looking for now because you
know your Niche better than me okay so
how to make passive income a
gbt and medium these are interesting and
we'll get to this a little bit later but
actually typing in the search like using
the search bar discovering the topic and
then seeing what's on the other side can
give you a lot of insights as your
brainstorming but here's all I was
looking for I was looking for two things
to compare and I found them
so well let's use chat
GPT versus some other stuff in fact one
of the things that's most powerful about
this is I don't even know what the other
stuff is we're about to find out
together live chat GPT
versus
now my heart has been tickled uh my
heart goes beep beep what are we okay
relax so chat GPT versus stockfish I
don't even know what stock fish is now
you might and I know you were saying
passive income but what we want to do is
follow this Rabbit Trail of
curiosity
and if we can make money with chat GPT
could we make money money with
stockfish so you're saying your Niche is
passive income Financial Freedom great
but what we want to actually do is then
within your Niche focus in on okay what
are some ways of creating passive income
there's literally thousands okay great
are you doing some stuff with AI now I'm
making a lot of assumptions if you're
like I know nothing about Ai and chat
GPT well you have two options you could
go research for 10 20 30 40 hours and
then turn that into a video it could be
very effective you'll get smarter in the
process this is literally why the
YouTube the content creator career is
the greatest career if you love the
topic that you're into because for some
it might sound awful to go research for
20 hours but if you're researching and
reading about and studying what you love
then it's kind of fun to do it sure it's
work still you know but it's kind of fun
to do it and then it's a benefit to the
viewer because I would love to watch a
video about um stock fish and some other
things understand what the different
opportunities are so let's say like chat
GPT versus stockfish we're going to do
the
search um it's a meme maybe I don't know
what it is okay broke chess just solved
chess okay so chat GPT so that so by the
way this is why you also got to go
deeper because apparently what that was
was maybe Chad gbt beat a chess bot or a
chess AI perhaps so let's actually go
chat GPT versus Bard I do know what BART
is The Showdown great now where we could
go as deeper on this and give me a
couple more niches because let me try
another one here but chat GPT versus
Bard like make money or let's go money
I'm just going to press enter here
because I'm wondering about people are
obviously making money which is right
for you okay okay great so and I might
abandon this this path because I'm still
trying to get into the head of what your
niche is but let's say um let's go
passive income passive
income uh real
estate versus stock market investing
that would be a direct passive
income
comparison which one will make you more
money which one is more
passive which one is more and and in
Verses Of course this is Dave and Dave's
influence but that's a lot of views 1.4
million views uh it's not even close
Bigger Pockets 23,000 views so that
would be another way to think about
verses but let's let's do one more on
this title
formula
um uh or one more Niche tell me your
niches tell me I'll go back up to to
find one off the grid cooking Katie's
Camp
kitchen so we're talking about
three topic YouTube topic formulas that
if you use these
wisely will lead to guaranteed views in
2024 and our first one was how to our
second one is verses and our next Niche
here on verses is camp off-grid cooking
so I need information you already
probably have this let's go tense for
camp
camping number one a good video top five
tents for camping what's interesting is
on the other side as kind of a side
quest here is how many of these are
faceless videos see people are out here
trying to buy now and you probably
should because if you're building a
personal brand maybe like this person
you've actually been there and it's your
own footage and you've tested it but
these top two videos just again as a
side quest are like like scripts written
from chat GPT random b-roll of stuff and
then like probably affiliate links oh
even link it up somebody didn't do their
job us and worldwide links no links so
anyways you can see that this is a uh a
faceless Channel what that should
Inspire is just the fact that there's
more videos you can create without
having to go buy every tent in the world
it is in my opinion or you might say hey
I'm I'm I'm doing a rundown I haven't
necessarily tried all these but I just
I've researched this magazine and
outdoor magazine and I did this and I
called two friends and here's now the
final list this is the one I've tried
I've tried this one as well here's the
other three that are popular those were
out of my price range like you could get
into more affiliate marketing stuff
again without having to like buy a lot
of products but that was some a niche
side quest for those that are fans of
the channel um and know some of these
topics that we talk about a lot so
here's what I'm after I am after uh okay
North Face white duck Coleman Eureka so
I'm gonna say white duck tent
versus so right there here it is here's
the secret idea
the only thing that came up at least in
in terms of these two Browns the only
thing that came up was white
duck and codiac 10 so what that tells me
though is again you can't get romantic
if you're like well and I bet Coleman's
on there too but if like Coleman doesn't
come up you can make the video but don't
be surprised when it doesn't get the
views using this process is key because
we're verifying
interest like imagine if you were going
to go to a friend's house they're
throwing a party you're with your
girlfriend boyfriend
spouse and and that you're like Hey
we're going to a party tonight and your
wife goes are you sure the party is
happening do you know it's happening for
sure and you're like yeah I mean I think
it is uh and she said it's two hours
away like I don't want to drive two
hours if I if you haven't even got a
text back and you're not sure the party
is happening and you're like well I
don't know I think it will and so then
you get in your car you drive two hours
you get get there the house is locked
the lights are off and the part's not
happening what's my point of sharing
that my point is if you haven't
verified that the party was happening
before you went on the two-hour Journey
then you're going to be really
frustrated when you get there and
there's no party too many people make
YouTube videos where they haven't
verified the topic they're about to make
they spend hours of work creating the
video they spend all this thought
creating the video and then they're
disappointed when the part's not
happening and there's no views this is
why we're verifying interest so if if
I'm going to make not only a versus
video which by the way could lead to a
lot of monetization opportunities um I'm
going to go Kodiak tent versus white
duck because that was what was
recommended to me on the other side of
that I'm gonna see okay Kodiak versus
springbar tents interestingly enough now
and we're not spending I'm going to keep
moving through these formulas but I
don't even know if anyone's made this
video because Spring Bar unless Spring
Bar is white duck and again forgive me
for 10
ignorance I don't really go outside
that's not true but kind of uh the last
tent you ever buy so the white duck but
this white duck is not even being
compared and this is what I mean when I
say every day we discover video ideas
that think media that have not been made
for people who say YouTube is crowded
for people who say YouTube is
oversaturated I'm like well then why has
nobody made the Kodiak tent versus the
white duck tent video yet people really
want to see it and you compare those two
tents with affiliate links now you got
passive income 50 to 100 bucks a month
coming in passively and that video will
be watched for the next three
years time to get the tents maybe borrow
one do you have one of those now let's
try one other one let's go like uh what
what was it co Kodak Colgate Cole
Coleman Coleman Coleman 10 more popular
this also why it can be powerful to
cover more popular products because
people are actually searching for them
so the Coleman tent versus the Ozark
Trail tent great okay here you go this
is and this a that's a good thumbnail
Coleman versus Ozark Trail nice verses
nice thumbnail 10,000 views very
Niche uh topic but really great for your
library arguably not super difficult to
make these
are link affiliate links to a $300 $200
tent here's a $35 tent and and I would
argue this video is ranked and going to
be ranked for a long time if not you
know ever you got another one here also
for a new channel outdoor FAQs remember
what we talked about earlier only 70
subscribers but 409 views the views are
out influencing the Channel's influence
why because of following the research
following this process following this
YouTube secret of using YouTube topic
formulas
to ultimately um come up with great
video ideas that again no fancy camera
needed not even a ton of talent needed
just some experience and let hit number
three is best now I'll tell you about a
resource we have in just a second
that'll just give you even more of this
but these three are really good place to
start so howto versus invest and we're
using the YouTube search bar so let's go
gaming news nerdcore nerd cave
best
PS5 game
2023 now okay that's that's some big
competition but a proven formula right
so and that was predict that was handed
to us that one might have been a little
bit more obvious top 10 best PS5 games
now watch Mojo it's going to be hard to
beat them push Square never heard of
them but maybe they're on the rise push
Square makes sense okay the square
button on a PS5 smart trademark even
what is this new channel okay but what
would be the opportunity here would be
to be go deeper so let's actually go
best
uh
PS5
and what we want to do and here's now
some tactics around the search bar best
PS5
space
um I because I was I was leaning Indie
but indie games but then also notice
that I know you said gaming news but
notice just all the different insights
we're getting here that could lead us
different directions the best internal
SSD now again another big opportunity
you're a gaming channel but what's the
best internal SSD best paying for your
buck size works with the machine the
best that's another money-making
opportunity for affiliate marketing
because you could link to the SSD drive
on Amazon or new egg or wherever
internet settings now again if you're
gaming news you might not be as
practical as this but notice this is
very interesting but I was leaning more
indie games so we go indie games and I
put another space keep going deeper is
one of the tips on the search bar best
PS5 space Indie Space games so then you
get best indie horror games PS5 and then
it does stop like I think it it pretty
much stops here
but you now could take it further
meaning you could say
2023 you could
say other nuances like that you might
end up saying top five top three a lot
of people doing top 10 lists there's
there's some fascinating reasons to do
top
5050 Ultra long form videos quote
unquote are underestimate you know time
codes chapters top 50 best indie horror
games I don't know like is there even
that many but like then people going
through they skip through maybe the
video doesn't get massive watch time but
people are like 50 like there's probably
a game on that list I don't know about
so this all happened and a niche that I
really am not that educated on from
using this search bar with these formul
right and so let's do one other niche in
regards to this um let's go okay let's
go evangelism we are all over the board
here Benjamin thanks so much for being
here so evangelism so like
best
evangelism
uh couple things that we see here now I
didn't know what would be predicted but
I think the mistake a lot of people make
is they get romantic about the video
ideas that they want to they want to
make what do I mean romantic the you're
making videos for yourself you're making
videos based on your emotions what you
feel you haven't actually researched and
verified interest and then you're also
complaining to me and you're frustrated
with the review with the views you're
getting what would happen if you
researched before you pressed record and
got clear on what people were actually
asking for so interestingly enough is
you go best evangelism Now TV shows on
HBO Max that's not relevant best
evangelism sermons interesting you could
get into a fair use in like aspect of
that maybe making a compilation of some
of the best evangelism sermons maybe
even titling the video best evangelism
sermon maybe you don't want to go that
direction that's a thought by the way
that's what the audience is saying they
desire but the one that stood out to me
best read evangelism you could do
highlights of that and people could
learn from you're still accomplishing
the same thing but right there that
Nuance Street just changed everything
because now people are probably wanting
to watch that because are probably
wanting to learn
some methods
some like Frameworks some uh apologetics
some ways of communicating the gospel
some ways of communicating their faith
or they're entertained by like there
could be a lot of reasons but that's
interesting but the one that stood out
to me is best books on evangelism okay
cool let's go ahe go ahead and search it
you will want this book for evangelism
here is one video that is only one
minute long that is an ad from an actual
book publisher that is the top rank
video five years ago someone did 10
books every Christian should read 13
books that change my life but here's
what's interesting the top five books in
60 seconds on evangelism okay so there's
there's one did pretty good too by the
way I mean oh 3,000 views but seven
years here's what I would say the
mistake is here is all these videos are
too short so I think not that they're
too short but 2024 make sure you
subscribed to this channel th media
podcast or if you like listening on
audio I've got some Banger videos coming
with top seven biggest trends for 2024
number one actually on the list high
quality High effort long form YouTube
videos will continue to dominate videos
will continue to get longer with video
viewership increasing on connected TVs
longer YouTube content is seeing serious
success podcasts are pushing one to two
hour range and we're seeing top creators
push into the 25 to 30 minute range on
videos with higher average viations
deeper audience connections uh Colin and
Samir predicted this as well I saw this
happening because I was noticing so many
channels like just go look at the result
like go look at channels look at Mr
BEAST's videos look at um that guy that
does these videos that always get a
million views uh they always go viral
about like
supp why your
supplements they're kind of like video
essays supplements are bad uh by the way
ruined my world because I spend a
zillion dollars on supplements and
Johnny Harris so if you ever seen like
Johnny Harris so 29 minutes his videos
are 29 minut and and they're all getting
now these are very difficult
videos and again this video ruin my life
but or just showed me I was probably
wasting a lot of money and probably
poisoning myself but that your
supplements are a lie thanks Johnny so
um
so I mean 21 minutes 29 minutes and by
the way of course this one's just came
out there's there's too many things to
compare on this channel but let me just
make a point that the video that's 11
minutes has a a lot less views than the
video that is
21 there's a lot of I I know somebody be
like oh that's you know kind of well but
and and it could be topic people maybe
watch the channel they don't care about
the recap I'm just saying though
that notied the views at you know I
here's 13 1.8 38 though got 2.1 this one
subjective channel the bottom line is
high effort high quality long form
videos I would be focusing on that in
2024 and so if we full if we go full
circle back
to wh what the research we're talking
about should lead you to notice a video
I just recently did said this book is a
cheat code for Content creation and my
video about one book was actually a 30
minute video I read the book which is a
heavy lift that a lot of people don't
want to do I took copious notes I then
synthesized them into a video made for
you let me know if you watch that video
this this book is a cheat code it's on
the laws of communication from
Maxwell and the videos outperforming
other videos on the channel it's rising
and notice too like even the way that
video was
positioned was different than what our
research is doing uh here but but
nevertheless we're verifying okay do
people want to read books on evangelism
what is what could we learn from the
videos that are already out and that was
a long side quest to just say I think
they're they're too short I think that
if you were
to if you also spot different formulas
like people saying I read 117 Finance
books here's the 17 things that really
matter what's fascinating about that
formula is nobody wants to read the 117
books and it's this whole idea that when
you save people time when you get people
good information and you are a
synthesizer anyways so just a couple
thoughts on you maybe wouldn't have
thought we would have gone to Street
evangelism books on evangelism when you
mentioned your channel was about
evangelism you could have been thinking
about something else which reveals to me
that there is massive opportunities that
you can't see yet like if you ever see
somebody who's doing better on YouTube
than you are it's probably because
there's something they're doing that you
don't know that's why getting
information and and and learning and
being a part of streams like this is
huge because there's whole series of
videos or whole clusters of video topics
that would be so relevant for your
channel I would even argue they're lwh
hanging fruit but sometimes they're may
be hard to see or sometimes you dishonor
it sometimes we like have this martyr
complex where we're like I don't want
the lwh hanging fruit I want to climb to
the top of the tree get cut up by the
branches just to prove you know like
it's not necessarily the person who puts
in the most time or whatever you might
be able to find a quick video like we
started this whole stream on doing like
how to set up your woodworking shop
where you're like I'm going to shoot
that right now like thanks Sean I'm
gonna go shoot it just shot it on my
phone like stitched it together now it's
the best performing video on my channel
not because of a camera not because of
talent because of the right information
because of the right research tools and
applying the information we discover
properly if you enjoyed this content and
want to take your YouTube channel to the
next level just click or tap the link on
the screen or go to tube 1K
challenge.com to join our next live
YouTube challenge you'll learn our best
tips and strategies that are working
here at think media and I think you'll
love it